[Music]
hello everybody welcome to career corner
rear corner I like today we're gonna be
talking about careers and yes this
company is a bit unorthodox in how we
work and it's a team of freelancers is a
team of independent contractors and
people are a business of their own and
it's different because most of us are
used to being what is called
traditionally a double YouTube right
it's a it's it's typically if you're a
salaried wage or you're a part-time or
full-time worker or you work at retail
or most of these situations you are on a
w-2 tab no but when you are freelancing
you go on I think a 1099 yeah 1099 1099
that's a different type of type of form
that you return but you are now looked
upon as a business that is offering
services and this is almost a standard
in entertainment or independent
contracting a film crews or whatever or
whatever like hookers are 1099 yeah
hooker service providers as long as you
know only fans girls or guys yes yeah
but also guys that are fitness coaches
that come in and they rent gym space and
Mark can maybe give us some info on our
I don't know
but also guys that might come over and
paint your house or they might build a
[ __ ] pool or whatever so it is a wide
range of professionals and give me a
funny look no no because I think Bart
did both of those things yeah that's why
I looked at him I thought those three
things in a row one of those things yeah
yeah well I think you paid for the other
things with one thing with the with the
fitness thing but there is a huge
movement now I think especially in our
generation of people moving toward more
this freelancing and side hustle world
Deuteronomy
yeah as I said gig economy yeah it's
kind of cool I don't know about you guys
but for me it was it was kind of a it
was kind of a big shock to go from like
my w2 work to my contract work because
it was like beforehand like you were
just kind of like you'd interview for
the job once right and then you'd get
the job then you would just continue to
do that job for X amount of time I was
working retail and then now
like I'm doing an interview like almost
like every week or every month like try
and get another thing it's kind of we're
still doing interviews interviews for
what no it's like when you own I'm
trying to like get a job or something
I'm trying to get a new client you know
like send me send me a real with the
resume and then like we need to feel
your new project yeah if you're a good
fit for you know this particular thing
that I want to film or whatever they're
just like but they have to feel it out
so it's kind of weird going back to that
like interview phase again where you're
just constantly like you know trying out
of essentially for a bunch of these like
different people I just kind of bizarre
for me it's it was a big jump from you
know just going in and being you know
guaranteed the same kind of like work
every week do you like it do you like
that new like some of it I like the
excitement of like being able to like
try different things like every week and
different get to talk to different
people and meet different groups of
people and interact with different crews
and stuff but at the same time it's
[ __ ] scary
yeah the scariest part is the fact that
it's so unstable I yeah one week you're
working five days on a set and then next
week you're not working at all maybe two
weeks you're not working at all and
you're always on the search for the next
project to work on which is scary
because it's so unreliable or sometimes
you just have to like drop everything to
like go do a different project and
you're just sort of like I don't know
about you but you always kind of keeps
me on my toes about just like I have a
thing that I'm not sure if it's gonna be
a thing and I might need to just drop
everything and go do that things I
really want to shoot this but it's not a
guarantee it but you work a lot I see
you work I'm trying to now like I mean
I've been blessed with this company and
the other company I worked for evic
being like steady work and stuff but I
think to like kind of do more of this
like camera work that I want to do yeah
I kind of require this big scary leap
into like freelancing and that's
something that I'm still getting used to
that feeling of uncertainty you want you
to minister okay let's do your art yeah
he's literally hired literally just
happened you guys have no idea how
literally true those love an entire crew
ready to go I do say I have I have 30
pages of script so I need about 88 but
yeah we're gonna take on freelancing
really like you're the newest member you
get man four years ago three or three
years ago right yeah and then I I seen
you take it pretty good because man like
at your age I wasn't making as much as
you did how do you 23
you know yeah you know you know you know
how much he makes can I tell the world
yeah I guess they he makes a ball like
six grand a month
oh yeah I wasn't against it for not
making six grand a month you're 23
people that are 50 years old that wish
they made six grand a pad you just lost
a lot of fans you lost your lady a lot
of Pat fans 6 grand a month is a lot of
[ __ ] monsters say you want more of
that and that's why do these random so
hard and there's nothing about that -
yeah it just happened - Pat is what
happened to Dave Chappelle they
announced he's getting 40 million
dollars Pat supposed to get hit up by
his friends family their bags six grand
a month
oh [ __ ] patty put me uneasy sleep it out
nobody in reality come out the brother
out back what makes you think that's
normal because in reality it's not
normal for a 23 year old to make that
much oh no because 5 times 12 is what 16
K right so then 6 times 12 what's that
something - yeah 72 grand tax yet so
well Stuart says yeah cuz you're your
own business so that's the difference
right but 72 grand to put it into
perspective is like someone with a
nursing degree or like a high profession
you know or like a engineer or something
engineer or something like that and
that's a starting I guess right but it
is a starting they put them for me I
feel like I kind of capped I'm capping
at 70 records don't you okay you're what
21 or 22 just last year hey Pat would be
grateful we got you little piece of [ __ ]
and stop looking a gift horse in the
mouth
you son of a [ __ ] all right put it in
bar probably until we were 26 or 27
made about $1,000 a month yeah with our
expenses I was like I was like negative
600 every month
oh saying man I mean even my first two
years on YouTube I was making about
grandma yeah but it's different cuz
we're not freelancers we're business
owners so the freelancer can become a
business owner once they make that pivot
of being the only person providing the
service so here's the theory right is
like you you provide the service as a
a camera guy director guy editor guy you
do all the you do all the roles right
and then you get all the clients you get
all the people that are like Pat's the
map at school right and then you go hey
I have six grand a month why don't I get
someone who assists me for a grand a
month and all and then they can help me
out the plan now right and then you
build a team you build a business and
then now instead of just being a
freelancer now it's Pats film company
and that's the kind of I think steps you
want to take but some people they stay a
freelancer and then they just go up in
value so you don't build a team use
instead of making this your rate like
let's say your rate is a thousand
dollars a day right but people love your
skills so much that you're like nope
now it's five thousand dollars a day I
am right it's a great concept okay so
here's my here's my issue so how much
money are you making on the back of my
good man Pat here you piece of [ __ ] how
much money you make it on this man back
on the Mac of this man who's working his
ass off how much he making off of it to
be completely honest he takes all the
money that I made on my channel well
pretty much a that I don't make a profit
from him well okay so it's a it's a it's
a it's a give and take I'm investing in
him because my Adsense does not pay me
nothing but you're getting hell of brand
deals where it is subtly don't you go
but it's a give and take right because
if I don't get brand deals for several
months or whatever then pretty much I'm
losing money so it's a it's a balancing
act and that's the risk that the
business owner takes is you have to
invest in a Pat so you pay them first
and then you in hopes that Pat's efforts
will then free up your time so I don't
have to film and edit and then we team
up here he gets paid first and then I
could break the deals or someone else
could break the deals to bring in the
more money and then eventually you can
just do cash for gold outs
can I get see Joe make it as okay I
would love it love it love it
and dodging the cow is crazy gold you
can get cash for that gold did you know
that you didn't know that now you know
that this does make a [ __ ] ton is this
like a 1-800 infomercial but they always
are cash for gold anything is and he
needs one of those like dollar business
oh yeah
all our friends ya know there's a
documentary on that guy the question I
saw that guy the airport you did it in
the airport yeah you're talking about
Alaska what's his name is it [ __ ] say
your mask oh yeah he used to be at like
the Central Parking like doing firm
wants to give his breathe yeah you know
him and his wife Bank every [ __ ] night
and they're madly and like bang every
night David [ __ ] every night like
they're like old as [ __ ] what if she's
sick like we came back from Orlando last
night and she feels sick and we couldn't
[ __ ] that I love their documentary
though because he is legit a happy
[ __ ] like he just goes out in
his question mark suit and he's just
selling taxes and he goes back home and
then they he's like the key to a happy
marriage is [ __ ] every night in like
having a blast so that's why he wears a
questionmark suit because his wife wants
to [ __ ] a minute I guess makes sense I
guess Bart how much are you paying
Nadine
so that you can get rich off of his
[ __ ] to that and off of this hard
work I don't know if I I don't know if
I'm Garen rich off his hard work the
[ __ ] fat cat ass rich well Nadeem
lives in an apartment here to apartment
to apartment or he spends like 3 grand a
month to apartments no you've moved out
of one recently just moved up driving an
Audi wanted you not only have an Audi
he's now having a Ford f-450 suffering
suffering is Ford f-450 with his [ __ ]
Quad Cab a piece of [ __ ]
dude it's so [ __ ] it's a lot yeah why
does it happen like that when they think
the guys that are running and owning the
business is like the oppressor I don't
see the risk that you're taking like
what you say so cuz it's what I feel
like it's fair like I take the risk with
the money and my time and everything and
I might not get the reward right I might
lose the money but then the people that
that I employ are the people that I team
up with and hire they get paid no matter
what you could not get a brand deal next
month yeah and I'll still have to
forfeit it but then they still believe
that it should I don't know it doesn't
make any sense to me like where's the
fairness or even with like the JK news
channel where we got hit with the
apocalypse and algorithm [ __ ] us so
the amount that each video makes
decreased by like 2/3 but we didn't ever
change the rates on the editing rates
they still got paid they still get paid
the same and that's I think the
responsibility of a business owner is to
protect the team and their livelihoods
first before they get paid yeah but I
don't know if they're referring to
normal businesses or they're referring
to like these weird businesses I think
it's just projection of insecurity I'm
feeling you just see things and they
just assume these what did you say maybe
not always sometimes I think you know
there's some foundation there like some
people are genuinely getting [ __ ] out
there but alright but you know that not
always that's the problem is that some
people go well you're getting paid more
than these people and therefore that's
[ __ ] up
sometimes yeah that's business because I
dunno like you know there's car
companies that would move their whole
facility to dodge taxes and it's just
all a bottom-line game well go out of
country to doghouse yeah and then the
employees would go with them thinking
that they have a secure job and they
wouldn't lay them all out and it's like
dude they move to a different [ __ ]
state and then they they don't dirty and
I'm like yeah that happens in business I
guess do we all get grouped up because
of the shitty things that other
companies do that's [ __ ] up call
yourself a company so therefore you're
in the group with the corporations and
also there's a stigma behind the word
corporation or like franchise or like
business owner or like whatever because
they just see it as the
whole well-liked Cub all over that guy
people drive around and go out to dinner
they don't think like some corporation
owns this business that I'm at you know
like literally they don't think that
they don't know that what goes into that
like some person owns that business in
there they have to make that business
work and pay all the people that have
and should do they think that humans
didn't create these buildings and [ __ ]
and it was just like there when they
were born
I honestly think some do Wow like it's a
tree it'll always be there the giving
tree some do a lot of a lot of people
don't but some do and I'm mostly making
fun of them
[Music]